susana fuentes arrived early for her
fourth dose or her second booster shot
she's a recovering cancer patient so
like others here with underlying health
conditions she's more vulnerable to
covid19
i've had breast cancer three times so
obviously i have to be even more worried
about protecting myself although
everyone in fact has to worry about it
one year after chile began a massive
vaccination campaign against covet 19
it's begun rolling out its fourth dose
even children from the age of three and
older are being vaccinated here in this
country unlike in most in the region
there is no shortage of vaccines and the
secret according to president sevastian
pineda is that chile began purchasing
them even before they existed
[Applause]
inviting a small group of correspondents
for coffee pineda told us that he bet on
three laboratories that seemed more
likely to cross the finish line first
including pfizer and sinovac
the government began taking measures at
a very early stage and with strong
decisions to buy vaccines and to begin
vaccinating very early even with the
third dose
he says arrangements have already been
made to guarantee a fifth dose if
necessary
sunday although in chile there have been
no reported cases of animals being
infected the health ministry is taking
no chances
this week sandai became the first ape to
be inoculated at the boin zoo
sunday is a unique specimen in south
america the only pure bornean orangutan
with such an important reproductive
potential for the species which is why
we're focused on immunizing him first
and also immunizing the big cats which
are known to be naturally prone to this
problem
be they four or two-legged patients
health authorities say hospitalizations
and deaths from covert 19 have dropped
significantly since the aggressive
vaccination campaign began
but there's also an awareness that until
everyone can be equally immunized on
every continent chileans will likely
have to prepare for many more jabs
before this pandemic is over lucia
newman al jazeera santiago